after losing the President Trump in 2016
and failing to block Brett Cavanaugh's
confirmation Democrats are now looking
to change the rules their proposals
would alter the Constitution and upend
hundreds of years of precedent a growing
number of 2020 candidates are now
revolting against the current makeup of
the Supreme Court and want major changes
much more on that in a moment but first
Elizabeth Warren now making the idea of
abolishing the Electoral College part of
her campaign my view is that every vote
matters and the way we can make that
happen
is that we can have national voting and
that means get rid of the electoral
college all right so we've been say that
I've been talking about this for about a
year Jessie but this is coming because
Hillary Clinton when she lost a Donald
Trump she said we have to take a look at
the electoral college and now it's
almost become a litmus test amongst the
Democrats that they are all saying yeah
I think we have to take a look at this
electoral college thing get rid of it
because it's the only way they think
they can win in the future yeah they
know they can't beat them under those
rules so they're trying to rig the
system if I were a Democrat I would just
say I could beat Trump with the rules I
don't need to change it I'll get past
270 I'll read rack the map I will
rebuild the blue wall and I think that
looks much stronger than these people
right now who look extremely weak right
now I don't want the cities running this
country
I mean San Francisco is a homeless
paradise la is not much better and
Chicago is like a corrupt shooting
gallery and look what New York did to
Amazon I don't think we need to give
them any more power than they already
have what they're trying to do is
they're trying to disenfranchise flyover
country they're only there four times a
year anyway but they don't want to have
them have any more power and Liz Warren
thinks she knows more than Ben Franklin
we designed a constitutional republic to
prevent mob rule and that's the point
and what they're trying to do is short
sir
get all of these systems in place
because they know they can't be trumped
they want to lower the voting age to 16
they want to impeach they want to stack
the court they want to kick
conservatives off television all of
these things they're doing because they
know they can't win right now the
founding fathers you know the
Constitution yes right of them in high
school you know where it's called the
United States of America if you go for
it to a national popular vote it would
be the United people of America except
maybe not so United yes talk about voter
suppression Dana yeah
Liz Warren she's either cheating to get
into college or cheating to get out of
college this is a contest among the
candidates of who can go further let's
get rid of the electoral college oh yeah
let's make the Supreme Court have term
limits oh yeah let's have an electoral
college replaced with a poetry slam
contest and the losing side has to give
all their salaries to reparations
they're caught they're doing this to
your point because it's hard to
challenge Trump on his record right now
because the economy is booming right
what's your alternative to that not
booming I mean that's what what do you
got and what's interesting with so you
hit sell these guys and girls coming up
with these so-called revolutionary ideas
they're just throwing stuff up there to
see what sticks oddly enough they got to
admit Trump has is more likely to come
up with new ideas that have challenged
the Republican orthodoxy and the party's
orthodoxy and any ideologies orthodoxy
when you think about North Korea trade
prison reform and and Syria the
Democrats have been chasing chasing
collusion for two years that's why
they're devoid of any kind of strategy
because they've been so lazy they're
just open for impeachment and they got
nothing they should try to challenge him
on ideas that would be interesting the
problem is his ideas are sometimes
similar to theirs right and also what do
you think about wanted that those like
Jessi's point of if you're a Democrat
and you're running the electoral college
is not going to change for the 2020
election like maybe they want to do it
in the future it's not going to so
somebody if on the Democratic side
should say I can win in the current
system
I think people acknowledge that thing I
don't think there anybody is saying I'm
gonna change for 2020 right no
I'm just saying that why waste all this
energy Tohno because it's a good idea
because I think it's the point well I
mean for example when you vote for a
governor you vote one man one vote and
in the current electoral college system
it's not one man one vote it's a vote
from a vote coming from a vote coming
from Wyoming is worth more than a vote
coming from California that's not fair
on the face issue in the house it's like
you're talking on we're not talking
about that we're talking about the
presidency the boat for the president
electoral college applies only to the
presidents I know so it doesn't matter
but that's what I'm saying to you is
this is not about Democrats being sore
losers this is about Democrats coming up
with ideas in keeping with the founding
fathers the founding fathers engaged in
of keeping with no it's exactly wrong
the founding fathers created a
constitution that is able to evolve with
the changing nation and so what you get
is things like doing away with the
three-fifths compromise Jesse say hey
you know what we made a mistake about
this we did it in order to establish
this country because we needed the slave
states but we know it's wrong and so we
undid it but you think amendment let me
finish once how about women voting the
Constitution did all out when it was
created but guess what it does now so
when you put forward ideas like this
it's healthy it says Jesse and Juan
should have a debate we can argue it
nobody's saying we're gonna break the
rules we're saying let's put forward
ideas that in fact might be more
representative of the country we are
today and they can have a debate and
then they could amend the Constitution
but you know that's not going to happen
made this comment in Mississippi writes
a small estate so there are more voters
in San Diego County than there are in
all of Mississippi so if you're a
candidate and you actually it's a race
to get to the popular vote rather than
to the equatorial college why would you
go campaign in a small state exactly and
that's why I feel like the arguments are
antithetical to the whole approach
anyway because no matter what the
counter is that the same thing is going
to happen it's just you're going to
continue to ignore the flyover country
which is exactly why President Trump was
elected because people felt ignored on
policy and so now they're going to be
ignored for according the vote I think
and also
think it goes against even the arguments
for the citizenship question for example
if voting is the basis on which all of
these arguments lie then there's a
hypocrisy on so many levels and that's
how to me it gets interpreted poorly in
that way and I think it also wastes
everyone time if there's that there's
that national popular vote interstate
compact none of its ever going to get
anywhere and yet this is just rhetoric
that's wasting everyone's time trying to
get there when 270 is not going to be
achieved for those states there was one
other topic we wanted to get to because
the electoral college is one thing the
Democrats talking about but also 2020
candidates are calling for a major
shake-up of the Supreme Court watch this
what if there were five justices
selected by Democrats five justices
selected by Republicans and those ten
didn't pick five more justices
independent of those who chose the first
tenth one idea that I think is
interesting is you have 15 members but
only 10 of them are appointed in the
political fashion five of them can only
be seated by a unanimous agreement of
the other tenth I think they stole a
Supreme Court seat can we keep it at
night should we give it at night I think
I would like to start exploring a lot of
options and we should have a national
conversation term limits for Supreme
Court justices might be one thing they
give every president to be ability to
choose three people holding on to those
seats in ways that I don't think is
necessarily healthy president Trump
responding to those ideas earlier I
wouldn't entertain that the only reason
is that they're doing that is they want
to try and catch up so if they can't
catch up through the ballot box by
winning an election they want to try
doing it in a different way now we would
have no interest in that whatsoever
it'll never happen it won't happen I
guarantee or what happened for six years
all right no court packing well I mean
is it a coincidence they lose because of
the electoral college they want to
change that and now there's an edge for
the Republicans in the Supreme Court so
they want to change that if that's just
purely a coincidence they got to
remember you changed the rules you
change the rules for everybody ask Harry
Reid how that worked out for his own
party
it's very short-sighted to decide when
you lose that you're going to change the
rules because that the other side is
smarter than you
they'll just catch up yes figure it out
that sounds like an argument against the
national emergency I'm glad you brought
it up but I think the bigger problem
with a bigger problem here is
the Republicans broke the rules instead
in terms of denying Merrick garland a
Supreme Court seat a year into a
properly elected twice elected President
Barack Obama they said though we're not
gonna let you appoint
no what I would do on and said I would
try adding seats in the Senate instead
of adding seats to the Supreme Court
because my show today wants to abolish
the Senate - I mean that where do you go
but you know what the conservatives in
the exit polls whan they said the most
important issue in 2016 when they were
coming out of the vote was the Supreme
Court and if the Democrats are gonna run
on messing around with the Supreme Court
that is going to activate the
conservatives so much in 2020 you're not
gonna see turn I fancy Justice Roberts
who is a Republican is concerned about
the credibility of this court that it's
seen as simply a rubber stamp for
whoever has the political majority it's
mostly Republicans much of a rubber
stamp nation people why do you want to
rub it raw why do you want to then water
it down if you take the Senate and you
take the White House that means there's
going to be a watered down sir Perry
boys are gonna rubber stance socialism
you you're missing the point which is
restore the credit so that you and I
could trust that it's not just the
political integrity of the court more if
Hillary Clinton had won and she had put
two Supreme Court justices on I don't
think that the Democrats would say that
the credibility of the court was in
question of course not we wouldn't have
candidates saying they have a confidence
crisis which is what Kamala Harris has
said in SCOTUS I think this is
absolutely ridiculous and I think you
know we saw this in the 30s this is what
Roosevelt went through it was a complete
waste of taxpayer dollars and it
fractured the party and it didn't work
because it for 80 years the justices the
seats were messed around with in the
1800s and then it ended term limits
which candidates are also throwing
around needs a constitutional amendment
to achieve that that's in the
Constitution these judges serve for good
behavior they can be impeached and
that's it so I also think it kind of
belies an ignorance with all of them
talking about it but I personally want
my lawmakers to focus on making laws and
not monkeying around with the amount of
seats that they're gonna put on when
that's not that's not what we're here to
do at all and that's not going to change
anything and in terms of if you
if there is some type of crisis in
confidence then to me that rhetoric is
just stirring the pot anyway because for
example a coverage race that if they
invent those quart invented the
individual right to bear arms the court
didn't invent that that's in this in the
Constitution so I think all right well
obviously we've got lots of issues to
talk about with 2025 hours the Senate
replaced with puppies I bet ya I'm still
gonna stick up for Wyoming and say keep
the Senate